full today
and here we go
okay moved the wrong night already yeah
should have gone lauren says knight c3
lawrence trent yeah once everyone's seen
that video course i'm sure knight c3
will become much more popular but
this one maybe
a sensible approach right now as well
we've seen this from magnus before in
this tournament now the white sea pawn
will push forward to put some pressure
on the black center and uh better late
than never the night does come out as
well white's knights occupying ice
squares
and okay interesting option there by
prague we might see a trade of pawns now
yeah in the center yeah he might trade
pawns he might repeat what he did
against um i think it was duda he uh
pushed his queen's pawn to
squat
two gosh two squares two squares
there we go you're right you're anchor
that moves on the board
and uh now there's a lot of tension in
the center it just depends who breaks
that tension uh we talked about the
isolated queensborn simon in the last
game we could well see something similar
this time
yeah i mean prank's got to do something
um
drastic here really to get some chances
a totally symmetrical position on the
board but that always should favor the
person with the move which is magnus
and it's really hard to know what pawns
exchange what pawns here if you're not
used to the position but obviously both
of these players are very used to what's
happening here um i mean talking about
chess ball courses lawrence trent just
brought out his one knight c3 course
going check it out and uh i remember of
course i did recently mikhail towels
best games he actually got this position
as well and there was some little move
with a3 um that he played but okay we'll
have an exchange and clarification yeah
there are two strategies in the last
position either you continue playing the
waiting game and kind of keeping the
complete symmetry or you trade off and
you bring your bishop out and this one
actually
wait let me just recall
with uh with that last night move i
think we've gone differently but if
magnus had captured a pawn in the center
with his own pawn that was a complete
replica of the time pregnant beat magnus
carlson oh two months ago so magnus he's
clearly studied that game and he's
chosen something different correct me if
i'm wrong ivanka but earlier if he'd
played e takes d4 rather than knight
takes d4 so it this is different now but
it was the same first few moves as uh
that infamous clash between these two
when pragnando won and now it's actually
going into something very similar to the
last game same pawn structure but now
pregnant is black rather than white look
at that isolated pawn in the centre of
the board pragnanda played against the
isolated pawn last time maybe he was so
impressed by what magnus did against him
by magnus's win but now he's taking on
the same pawn structure himself so
um okay interesting
dynamic decision there and uh i'm just
looking at this position i'm thinking
this is very similar to
an opening that i could find with colors
reversed um the karakan pan of bobbinic
this is almost identical to did you have
this kind of thing against david
actually with the black pieces
this type of position many times against
david yeah i think i've called someone
also with colors reversed as well
because there was a time we were playing
each other quite frequently and he would
throw everything against
but he was very young
[Music]
and i i would get these terrible
positions but you know
and i've had this exact position myself
i've got to say
from the white side uh a couple years
ago uh in some rapid tournaments and
okay here we go the bishop stepping
forward to attack this white knight
magnus is about to force that bishop to
make a decision he was about to click
his pawn
harry the h1 click it one square foot oh
yeah
that's a very interesting decision
because i would have thought it was a
lot more thematic to actually drop the
light squared bishop back
and just keep keep the kind of pawn
structure a little bit more flexible on
the right side because it might not be
ideal to push harry it might be better
to push
gary
one square forward i kind of call that
kind of try not not like ziggy zag
formation the wall when i set it up with
the black pieces i love it i'm like yeah
break that one down if you can i think
the first thing though is to break this
pin and magnus is trying to ask this
light square bishop to either capture
the white knight a trade which most
likely is fine for white or that white
uh the black light square bishop is
going to have to take a step back and
then magnus can set up
a very well-known motif so yeah this one
is coming now javanco the white bishop
is going to retreat and break the
pressure along this diagonal there we go
so a combination of the two plans you
mentioned there and this is still very
well known territory
and white has a couple of ideas in mind
purely to do with trading off pieces
because the isolated pawn favors white
if it gets down to an end game and this
is a must-win situation for pregnant
let's just bring up the results so far
in all the matches magnus has won both
of the first two games so pragee has to
win this one and the next one to take it
to tie breaks in the match between duda
and mom jaro duda is still up by one
point they are now playing game three as
well and liam he was able to win game
two against eric hanseny is up by
one point and denise geary and jordan
pham freezed two draws they are tied now
playing game three and we do have
another move we do have another move and
very sensible by prague he brings his
rook to a slightly more centralized
square that's an open file once the
knights get out the way
and uh also just creating a square for
the black dark square bishop to go back
and hide on potentially and yeah this is
the strategy that i was mentioning this
is very well known magnus trying to
force the light squared bishops off the
board you have to trade pieces before
black gets ready to attack you
and uh it's inevitable now prague's
light squad bishop is going to get
traded and it's going to get captured by
this white knight sitting on the edge of
the board
it's an interesting decision there just
uh kind of stepping back rather than
trading bishop for bishop he's gone for
a bishop for nitrate
yeah
yeah it's one of those it's the isolated
pawns and this is the theme between
these two players at the moment and
there's even ideas where magnus can try
to win the pawn immediately by by taking
the bishop and then moving the knight
and maybe we can show that one
and getting rid of the defenders of the
isolated pawn um you know black would
love to get an attack going by uh
creating some battering round for the
queen and bishop but it's very hard very
hard to do that and in this position
he's maybe one tempo too slow to get to
get any frets with the black pieces here
yeah as you mentioned this uh this
battery ram idea retreating the bishop
and then for example if white were to
give you an extra move then to line it
up uh line up this checkmate trying to
sneak into the weakness uh that white
has left on the dart squares this would
actually be checkmate if the queen can
sneak in but of course white won't allow
this if the bishop steps back in this
position white gets greedy and captures
a pawn in the center
no real way to set up this battery now
uh because for example if you step
forward with the queen we just see a
trade of knights this is actually czech
and then the queens disappear so black
is just one move too slow not only is
white one of pawn uh in this position
but white also has these dominant
bishops look at how great they are on
the two longest diagonals on the board
controlling everything so i'm expecting
now in the current position that we have
on the board magnus to just bring his
bishop to this square and a lot of
pressure on this guy probably prague's
idea is to challenge the bishops on this
diagonal and uh if i could recall
correctly this is still something that
we've seen earlier in the tour uh maybe
last season and uh okay instead magnus
maybe with that in mind brings his
knight forward this is the other idea
you mentioned simon hitting this bishop
and uh if the bishop drops back
potentially trading off this black
knight in order to win a pawn in the
center
so it's looking pretty good for magnus
we've got to say right now but prague
has his ideas
and okay pressure it's all about this
guy this pawn in the middle of the board
cool now pragnanda he is struggling
against magnus carlsen must win
situation right now but what a
tournament he is having and uh remember
tomorrow the very special chess talk
that ivanka had with pragnanda it's a
long deep dive interview into his life
will be released on chess 24 if you
click on collection as we see anish
geary leaving that must mean
uh the game with jordan has finished is
that a draw that is indeed a draw the
third draw so if we have a winner in
game four that will be the winner of the
match if not tie breaks but yeah
remember the chess talk released
tomorrow with
this super talented 16 year old
pragnanda and
it's only available to chess 24 premium
users and during the esports cup you do
get 40 off premium subscription
if you use
the code
esports cup
so a great
sale right there
is there chances for him to make that
comeback in this game
he's made it imbalanced that's a good
thing so it's kind of imbalance of
pieces white has the two bishops as we
mentioned but black has the tricky
knights and the pawn structure
definitely uh not symmetrical anymore so
maybe maybe he has some small threats
here as well uh potentially let's say
white if if we can show this maybe
pushes a3 ways to move somehow uh we can
go for this battering ram uh again and
uh this okay this hasn't happened but
this kind of idea is very dangerous if
white blocks that queen you can
potentially now sacrifice the rook in
the middle of the board opening things
up so there is danger for magnus i mean
i'm not sure this is working 100 but it
looks very scary so there's still
chances certainly yeah and that's why
magnus may be scared of a variation like
this one um in this current position he
has just traded a set of knights magnus
is really heading or trying to force
this game towards a draw if possible
practice recaptured with the pawn so no
more isolated pawn and center but there
is however an isolated pawn over here uh
on this side so alice the a pawn
isolated and lonely magnus meanwhile
improving the queen and at least now
after the black bishop and queen line up
for this battery along the diagonal he
can safely block it with a pawn the idea
that simon mentioned of rook takes pawn
no longer in the air because white's
queen defends
this e3 square so yeah great defense
there for magnus carlsen also eyeing up
this pawn
it's looking very safe actually now for
magnus the more i look at it it's hard
for black to create any attack here
anymore i i have to say i i don't like
this position for pragnanda at all my
experience is is that
white will be feeling very comfortable
for a lot of the reasons that you
mentioned but
like simon points out you must always be
on your guard tactically you have to
have your a-game on there because
they're always going to be
cap captures and checks and potential
attacks that could be coming your way
but once you navigate that
yeah great great chance for winning
black black does have this lovely bishop
at least which is pointing towards the
white king and that's always going to be
some threat towards white i mean
whatever happens black can threaten
check mate so that's uh that's something
you need to always bear in mind so you
very much when you approach these type
of positions you you don't look at it
from your own point of view you try to
kind of think about what does your
opponent want to do and then you make
the adequate preparations that's how
i've always dealt with this type of
position
and um okay it's te it's tense and it's
tough and you often have to use up a lot
of time
um calculating everything out but
good long-term prospects i get very
excited about long-term prospects yeah i
mean maybe black should try to move the
knight into the center now this is
something but again more exchanges can
happen then and uh the danger is that
prague obviously has to win this game as
well um
draw is just not good enough i mean how
do you beat the world champion on-demand
with the black pieces drop a mobile
phone in his pocket
give give it a ring and i hope he hope
he gets
hope he gets banned
his mouth to be a bit uh a bit wonky yes
drunken mouse so yeah
well one thing that we have seen is that
at times he gets complacent okay we do
have a move is it a dramatic move no
black just keeping a pawn on a safe
square all right but in the match
between jordan van furies and anish
geary they have played three draws game
three finished and uh whoever wins game
four will be the winner you're standing
there with a niche now right sweater
yeah nish came by to have some sushi
here on the side so he's he's picked out
his food but he's also taking a quick
draw was that in time so you could get
time to eat
you could say so it's quite hard to find
time to but actually um no just the game
went this way i thought it was a
sensible uh end
last black game that you played you're
playing a black game again now you faced
an unorthodox opening do you know where
it comes from yes i know i know it's an
homage to lawrence trent who who did the
193 course
there are many
uh first moves nowadays that people can
play 93 is uh
amongst uh amazon are you expecting more
of the same for the last game well i'm
not going to tell you what i expect not
to give anyway anything to my opponent
who's watching this interview with great
interest
it's a dutch match up here but let's
also have a
a little look at what fonfotis had to
say after they finished their game
you're left with a white game now to try
to
score and win this in the regular time
yeah it's a good feeling of course at
least the match will take four games as
well which is uh
not too usual for me i've lost two
matches in three games already so i'm
very happy at making such a quick draw
with the black pieces
for the last white game you'd prepared
for all of
10 12 minutes by random chance as
laurence trent was walking by who who in
this area have you gotten your
inspiration for for the next white game
yeah i think i'll turn to my second for
this one hopefully something up his
sleeve and
otherwise it's going to be tough like i
think
thank you jordan so uh just watch it
johan sebastian he's ready to offer some
brilliant insights here to uh juden pond
forest before the last game
oh that's going to be a very cool game
if we have a winner then that player
will be the winner of that match it's
prestigious two dutch players but if it
is a draw then we will head to some
dramatic
tie breaks and eating some sushi there
in ishgiri
what kind of have you guys ever been at
a tournament where you actually been
able there's like some very classy nice
sushi stacked up for you in between
games normally a greasy kebab or
something
some cheese cheese roll or something you
get at chess tournaments cheese rolls um
old stale bread
no you can get some nice food but i mean
you have to work your way up the ranks i
think because when you're when you're
young you normally in england at least
lots of tournaments are in school halls
somewhere you might have someone
catering with some very bad coffee and
you know and putting some you know one
pound sandwiches together um but yeah i
think there's nothing amazing not as
good as this food anyway i don't know
about you guys if you've had any
great food somewhere even at feed day
events even kind of to qualify for the
world championship cycle we'd be lucky
to get kind of
water with plastic cups i mean that's
like the maximum normally so
um this is uh refreshing biscuits and
nuts that's my experience very rarely do
we get that luxury
biscuits
you go too clean yeah
do all tournament organizers get some
inspiration from the sushi chef here the
players are really enjoying it yeah
sushi chef and a sushi chef and last
season the tour final i really loved it
when you guys had that uh tea person
coming in making these beautiful brews
what about cocktail bar can we can we
introduce that yeah i'm down with that
yeah i'm down with that in the playoffs
can make the chest really interesting to
see a niche shaking some cocktails after
the first game making a quick margarita
for himself so yeah actually in our
podcast with anish released today uh he
did say if he had to have a drink named
after him it would be a fruity mocktail
ah fruity mocktail non-alcoholic one
unfortunately he's a true professional
absolutely all right we do have a couple
of moves
in this one with a drawer magnus
grossman will be the winner of the match
against pragnanda what way is this game
heading it's heading towards safety for
magnus we did see a few moves black's
knight did indeed leap into the centre
of the board as simon uh indicated and
magnus barely paused for thought he
whipped off the white uh the black
knight with his bishop so no more bishop
power for white but
a safer king
so black can still line up that battery
at some point the one that we've been
discussing a few times black's queen and
black star squad bishop lining up
towards the white king but any inroads
towards that white king will just be
blocked off
by a pawn so still looking relatively
safe white has an easy plan as well of
stacking up the rooks towards black
central pawns some weaknesses there
and it's just hard to see any
kind of clear attack no direct path
forward for pregnant and whilst
pragnanda is thinking about a way
forward well we do have some selfies uh
not quite any extreme selfies so i have
to say that wait one second you can
you're not going to be disappointed
right because these ones are with our
chess pets okay that's right that's all
right yeah
is uh watching from vienna with their
dog it's uh well
yep
maybe the dog's eating the internet
cable there so uh
excuse me i was talking to simon about
it earlier uh when it comes to chess we
rarely see dogs chess players seem to be
cat people not dog people yeah don't
they yeah ashley is a dog person
what about irony
has got his famous famous dogs that is
the famous dog but you have to agree
with me there are more i i
think it's if you're a chess player you
have to walk a dog right so if you go to
a tournament for two weeks it's pretty
hard to walk that dog but a cat can is a
bit more self-sufficient you know
maybe with online chess now there's
gonna be more dogs because people are
more home yeah
in fact one of the best tournaments i
played as a child i mean they used to
have a dog a dalmatian running loose and
you know sometimes you'd be playing and
they would a dog would pass between your
legs and it'd be like this is the
coolest thing ever what kind of
tournaments do you play dogs oh look at
the bar what's happening yeah
this happened a couple of moves ago
actually and uh black's rook has just
gone offside again yeah again like the
last game just like the last game prac
has put his rook on a square where it's
not actually doing too much he's lined
up the black queen and the black bishop
we mentioned this the black queen's
trying to sneak in to deliver a nasty
check to white but this can just be
blocked i think by a pawn and
it's because he needs to win prague it's
not because he made a blunder it's not a
terrible move uh in general but it's
just too slow and uh now i expect magnus
to push a pawn forward you could even
make an argument for white's king just
running away at some point
i don't think black has enough attacking
pieces unfortunately and it really looks
good to kind of push freddy two squares
forward block the diagonal
leave the look rook offside maybe we can
show this on the board because right now
there is this threat as mentioned of the
black queen sneaking in and giving a
check but just pushing the pawn forward
uh looks very good simon you were going
to mention that black could maybe well
yeah
i'd want to play this move but i think
white has a very uh useful
move that exchanges more pieces here is
one option but obviously to my eyes it
is quite scary when you get that pawn
there but uh magnus has has it under
control yeah this bishop move kills all
the fun so you don't get distracted and
capture this pawn because then this
really is a nasty check defended by the
bishop and white king is kind of forced
out into the open where it won't really
survive but instead of getting greedy
here you can block things down
and just take the safe approach this is
what i'm expecting from magnus just
trade off the bishops once the black
queen moves and complete safety magnus
making a face there maybe in the current
position he's thinking about something
else maybe he's even contemplating
allowing this check that looks
unnecessarily brave in this position
where you only need to draw as magnus
but you could make an argument for just
ignoring it black's attack after all
takes a long long time to get going you
could counter attack against this black
rook and uh not only do you attack this
black rook but
you also attack this pawn for a third
time with white's rook after all this is
just one check and maybe only a second
check and white's king does run to
safety and here white is actually
winning because the black rook under
fire and the black queen under fire at
the same time double attack instead
magnus going for the alternative
approach allowing the queen in as
mentioned super brave but if the queen
does jump in then white can simply
capture this black pawn i don't think
black's attack is scary enough white is
the first one to break through uh for
example a position like this with a
check on the eighth rank black's king
just as weak as whites
okay
it's uh super dramatic for pragnanda
he has to win this game it's must win to
take it to a game four as well
starting to look very good for magnus he
needs only a jewel in the game and i
guess then it's heading at least that
way for him it's looking good i mean
what is that black rook doing all on its
own
the real action is happening against
those black pawns
unfortunately i think just not enough
experience in this type of position for
prague yeah i think you need to get more
firepower in don't you and there's just
not any more black pieces that can
really join in the attack black still
had a knight for example yeah
dangerous or even a light square bishop
i mean then it would be really scary but
uh as it stands
not enough pieces and i think he needed
to
switch tack and maybe play on the
defensive but of course that doesn't
suit the match situation at all
yeah i mean i've studied these types of
openings quite a lot and this is
basically what black should not try to
do allow all these trades allow all
these exchanges and even before black
put his rook offside it's difficult to
find a plan white's plan is so simple
you build up against black central pawns
look at the two white rooks uh easy
targets for them but for black it's much
less clear so it feels to me as if okay
decent opening preparation by prague but
not really fully exploring the middle
games that arise and maybe something to
work on with his coach ramesh he'll have
learned a lot prague
even if he
falls to defeat in this game he'll have
learned a lot and uh
he will improve and be better for this
match
what can you say about magnus's play
today
very good yeah yeah i mean he's he's
just done everything right today um he's
uh
not sure you know just perfect play
really in oh look at that what is that
face about well that's very i mean maybe
he's confused i'm confused to be honest
yeah maybe he just thinks he's not well
look at that that's
i mean what is that i mean i guess he's
thinking he can move the queen to that
square you said but
what what's he he's even talking to
himself there i think he's confused
either something's happening with the
tech side maybe computer froze mouse
throws or something or he's just
confused about pregs last move and i'm
mightily confused as well the white
queen can just come in i don't really
understand what this last rook move does
for prague
let's maybe take a look at prague as
well
to see his reaction after making this
move
we see the bar has shot up even more as
well yeah it looks like the black rook
which was already offside has gone to a
square that's
not even better
than it previously stood
i'm struggling to find what black wants
to do maybe he wants to bring his black
rook across to the f line to look at the
white king but
it's so slow white's queen as we
mentioned is going after those black
pawns immediately yeah i mean he's look
yeah i mean he's very very surprised and
he doesn't he doesn't normally show that
much emotion he means like uh nepo does
when he's when he was playing the world
championships but
you rarely see this from magnus i think
what prank's got to do though he's got
to take a lot away from this uh it's a
learning experience and the best way to
learn is to play people who are better
than you and magnus is better than him
this is this is how i got better i
always played tournaments where i was
one of the lowest rated players i'd lose
horribly the queen does come in now
attacking all those weak points and
eventually you start to beat the players
that you'd lose to originally uh but
yeah i mean the pawns are gonna start
start dropping here aren't they it's
like domino's now everything's falling
in black's position and yeah rook takes
porn and look at that that rook is now
going to venture two squares forward at
least and yeah it's just going to be
so problematic for black um yeah on the
subject of learning i mean i was reading
a book just now talking about how to
deal with the mindset of competition
because you know the dark side of
competition is that you have a winner
and a loser and often you can determine
that if you lose you're a loser which is
not the case so the mindset it was
advocating was that basically you should
approach it like student and teacher at
times both of you will be teaching each
other things and you'll be showing where
the weaknesses are and
so have you seen this queen f6 move this
year
just like yeah i totally agree with you
vancouver david's
i mean magnus won the world
championships by uh this brilliant queen
h6 move uh and it'd be lovely to see him
at some point this this is a beautiful
thing to show maybe just to quickly show
i don't think it even works actually
unfortunately
okay um oh yeah because of g5 but it is
very pretty yes so white is about to
crash through on this eighth rank black
can give a check but it's only one check
the white king runs away to safety and
black is reduced to taking pawns which
are irrelevant i think prague's actually
going to resign so let's race through
this rook takes rook is one move but
after the black rook recaptures both me
and simon here okay he defends with his
bishop both me and simon thought that
white could give up the queen and go for
checkmate it doesn't quite work the king
can actually escape by pushing a pawn
forward but uh either way this is the
type of thing in the air and uh right
now we did see the black bishop step
forward but a trade and white's rook
coming forward this is going to win the
black bishop the black bishop is pinned
let's go back to the players we're going
to see a result it's just game over
black's king is the first to fall
and uh prague is getting ready to resign
magnus taking the win any moment now
wow after
just being on fire pragnanda winning
three matches in only three rapid games
that streak ends today magnus carlsen is
about to win this match in only three
rapid games he put on an entertaining
fight to pragnanda but magnus carlsen
still is the boss
and there we go prague shaking his head
i mean he can't be too disappointed he's
just gonna look ahead he's done great in
this tournament so far okay his
performance rating won't be 3000 anymore
but he's still done extremely well and
magnus has just been at its best today
you can't yeah you can't get too upset
if you're playing the best player in the
world and they're on form
yeah he's he's showed real class today
isn't he and
you know he's never really been in any
danger and uh he might even finish by
winning uh well he's going to win isn't
he obviously here yeah and there we go
he's worked out the checkmate as well
finishing his style yeah uh there's a
checkmate on the e7 squad after uh a few
moves uh this is really nice once the
black king takes the white rook i hope
prague is going to let us see this
there's the queen check the white bishop
is now going to give a check
the black king once it moves
okay it's checkmate next move
he doesn't allow it he doesn't allow it
now the check mate we want to see it but
what a performance by magnus what a
performance magnus carlsen wins this
match in three games and pragnanda
shakes his hand